manche leute vermisst man so gar nicht
aber sie kommen einfach immer wieder wie
zum beispiel donald trump der will
wirklich noch mal angreifen
diesen satz schockierte jetzt donald
trump denn er meint damit eine erneute
kandidatur als us-präsident klingt nach
einem schlechten scherz ist es aber
nicht denn bei den republikanern gilt er
als top kandidat für die wahl
2024 aber wenn wir unser seine amtszeit
zurück erinnern dann erinnern wir uns
vor allem an seine skandale twitter
schlachten kein handschlag für angela
merkel dem austritt aus dem pariser
klimaabkommen kriegsdrohungen gegen
nordkorea und dann doch die versöhnung
beleidigung gegenüber journalisten
und natürlich die stürmung des kapitols
im januar 2021
doch trotz allem ist donald trump selbst
überzeugter denn je vor allem von sich
selbst wenig überraschend also dass er
gegen die aktuelle regierung um joe
biden wütet er sagt amerika sei am boden
die höchste inflation die höchsten
benzinpreise der amerikanische traum
zerstört
wir müssen es vielleicht einfach noch
mal machen oder eben nicht am ende
können zum glück die wähler in den usa
entscheiden ob sich deutschland jemals
wieder präsidenten
darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit bild
reporter herbert bauernebel uns
zugeschaltet aus new york herbert es
gibt neue brisante enthüllungen im
skandal vom sturm auf das kapitol was
kannst du uns dazu sagen
ja es gibt hier zwei schienen die sehr
unangenehm sind für donald trump die
erste chinesin die hearings dem kongress
abgehalten werden bezüglich dahinter
könnte dieses unrühmlichen tages dieser
sechster januar 2021 als eben dieser mob
am trump anhängern das capitol gestürmt
hat hier gibt es immer wieder
enthüllungen die klar legen dass donald
trump so jedenfalls seine kritiker die
eine rolle als drahtzieher eines
möglichen putschversuches gespielt haben
soll putschversuche im sinne dass er das
wahlresultat eben den sieg seines
rivalen joe biden umdrehen wollte kippen
wollte das ist die eine schiene die sehr
politisch sehr unangenehm ist für andy
zweite allerdings könnte gefährlicher
sein denn das sind mögliche
untersuchungen innerhalb des
justizministeriums gegen donald trump
und hier geht es um mögliche
strafrechtliche vorwürfe die im
schlimmsten fall führt haben in einer
anklage münden könnten in einer
strafrechtlichen anklage das würde bei
einer verurteilung bedeuten dass es
möglicherweise sogar eine haftstrafe
geben könnte gegen trump die indizien
dafür sind ja es gibt immer wieder bei
den untersuchungen durch die
staatsanwälte des justizministeriums
fragen auch über donald trumps rolle und
viele rechtsexperten in den usa gehen
davon aus dass hier das
justizministerium auf hochtouren
arbeitet um eine mögliche anklage
vorzubereiten und trotzdem gilt er als
top favorit der republikaner hätte trump
dann eine chance zu einer wiederwahl
man hat donald trump bereits in der
vergangenheit mehrmals abgeschrieben und
er hat am ende immer gesagt es gab auch
immer wieder diese skandale diese
untersuchungen und alles ist an ihm
abgeprallt man erinnert sich an die
ermittlungen über die hintergründe
möglich - beziehungen nach russland und
weitere skandale alles hat donald trump
über überlebt was man in den umfragen
allerdings sieht ist das besonders diese
hearings zum 6 januar in politisch
geschadet haben dass er leicht gefallen
ist in den umfragen aber es wird hier
keinen in amerika geben der nicht sagen
würde dass donald trump neuerlich eine
chance hätte wiedergewählt zu werden als
präsident was würde denn eine wiederwahl
donald trumps für die usa für das land
bedeuten
eine wiederwahl donnert als würde ein
quasi ein rückfall in die zeit unter
donald trump sein oder eine eine tolle
zeit so jedenfalls seine anhänger der
wahlkampf hat für eben eigentlich fast
schon begonnen als er seinen den
jetzigen präsidenten joe biden
programmatisch kritisiert hat die ganzen
missstände in amerika angebrannt
gebracht hat von der hohen inflation bis
zur einwanderung all das sie wären
missstände die er dann eben beenden
würde er würde aufräumen mit all diesen
missständen hat dazu einige
abenteuerliche vorschläge bereits
gemacht wie eine sofortige todesstrafe
für drogendealer etc all das könnte
jetzt auf amerika wieder zu wollen
vielen dank aber bauer nebel live aus
[Musik]